to parent my child
even before i had any knowledge
i didn't even get to show support you
asked for support i didn't get a chance
your job was to educate my child in math
science english etc do your job and let
me do mine
that was jessica conan a mom who we
profiled on this show five months ago so
why was she so angry well mrs conan
entrusted her seventh grade daughter to
the spreckels california school district
and the district then turned around and
conspired to change the girl's gender
her name her pronouns all behind her
parents back
and at the time of our interview jessica
was considering legal action she and her
attorney harmeet dillon founder of the
center for american liberty are back
with us tonight with an update jessica
what can you announce tonight
so i uh first of all i want to say thank
you so much laura for having us um
exciting news actually that we are
moving forward
and we have filed lawsuit against
sparkle school district the two teachers
and the principal that has caused some
very serious damage to my child
harming this is from the lawsuit that
the center for american liberty filed ms
caldera and ms bakari instructed
students that they should not tell their
parents about their new gender
identities purposely failed to keep
equality club rosters or records so that
parents could not discover their
children's participation and held
equality club meetings during lunch as
opposed to after school so that students
who were too young to drive did not have
to ask their parents to pick them up
harmeet
if that's all true the lengths to which
they went
to cover this up
that's stunning
it is stunning laura and to be honest
with you when i first heard about these
facts it was really hard to believe but
in fact these teachers have actually
confessed on
video at the california teachers
association to
doing a lot of these things and not only
doing it but trying to teach other
california teachers
how to secretly run these clubs
away from the knowledge of the parents
and and laura first they told this young
lady that she was bisexual this was a
prepubescent girl
and then a few weeks later they tell her
no we think you're trans some of the
other facts in this lawsuit laura
include that these teachers during covet
actually creeped on the search engine
searches of these children who were
studying remotely to identify more
children to include in these types of
clubs and so
no parent should have to go through this
they have rights under the united states
constitution to direct the education and
the upbringing of their children and we
intend to hold these teachers the
principal and the school district liable
for the damage they've caused this
family
other families potentially
and for violating the civil rights of
these families and this cannot go on in
america
this
this everyone watching this tonight has
to be blown away because there's more in
this lawsuit i i can't even believe this
now ms caldera ms bakari again encourage
a.g that's your daughter jessica to
change her name to a boy's name as an
expression of the new identity they were
encouraged her to take on
jessica
this is a full frontal assault
on the traditional american family
on your family and on your belief system
is it not it it
i don't even know how you hold it
together frankly after this
100 it is complete violation it is
disrespectful it is um
to be honest you know it's it's some of
the most emotionally damaging thing that
you could do to a family unit to a child
um the things that i have found out
that i you know going through this
process and
who my daughter is becoming now it's
just so disgusting and i'm actually
really sad that i wasn't able to be
there for her the way that a mom should
have been you know there should have
never been any hiding from a mom and
there should have never been any type of
um you know they should have never had
that type of control over any type of
child anybody
harmed is this a recruitment tool
yes or no
that
laura and we these are not the only
children affected we've learned about
other children in this school district
and i've learned about hundreds and
thousands of families across the country
and so laura if people want to find out
more they should go to our website and
support this family libertycenter.org
support jessica all right jessica
harmeet thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else